we have this really amazing opportunity
to build a world that people want to
stay in for a really long time and have
that conversation with them it's really
exciting that this time it's a two-way
street it's not the one way street it
was over before we heard loud and clear
what players wanted they wanted more
that's what we've tried to do in the
dark below just bring bring people more
it's got more crucible multiplayer maps
got a new strike brand new raid new
weapons got a new gear or story was a
core goal for us so we created eros
I am eres the last
I have seen with the hide call of God
I told zavala we mustn't wake them
heiresses many things she's a vendor in
the tower so she has loot armor for you
to get as you progress in the story
kills son but she's also the main quest
giver for the whole dark below story
live on the girl is wicked desperate
keep your mighty Paris and other
Guardians tried to kill Kuroda it didn't
go well and she spent years hiding in
the tunnels below the moon waiting for a
chance of revenge
the ritual has begun our spoor we're
going
so one of the new things we're doing
with the strike is we're integrating it
into the storyline
we wanted heiress to tie everything
together coches old is waking so she's
moving in two strikes historian the raid
and making it all part of that one
cohesive experience when we sit down is
the right team to talk about building a
new raid we start with what's the theme
the theme of the baltinglass was a
dissent with crotas end one way trip
became that theme that a bunch of our
mechanics and experiences were measured
against
so expansion one has three new maps
there's Pantheon sky shock and the
cauldron Pantheon is our first truly
symmetric map there are three lanes
there's cliffside center
and waterfall
we wanted to have better
compartmentalized infantry zones so sky
shot gives us that you've got the
vehicles owning one space and you got
infantry owning another
and then we have the cauldron you've got
these unique locations on each part of
the map that are very easy to call out
you've got bone room we've got bridge
room you've got the altar which is what
makes it such a good small team map and
a good Rumble map
in the dark below you get new guns new
exotics more choices of exotic armor
that changed the way the characters play
well you've got eros who's got a high
theme weapon she's got shaders she's got
class items she's got bounties for
experience
we're gonna have new crucible weapons a
full set of new raid weapons new
vanguard weapons and new legendary
weapons across the board certainly we're
going to explore some stuff that we
think is really cool but we're also
gonna listen to the community and build
some things that they think is pretty
cool just like we ship the game and it
got into real players hands and they
started to play and learn so much the
same things gonna happen with the dark
below I think that's going to change how
we look at expansion too and what we do
next